joining us now is former hud secretary
retired neurosurgeon and author of the
upcoming book created equal dr ben
carson dr carson thank you for joining
us it does seem for years that voters
kind of gave higher marks to democrats
than republicans on the issue of
education
why do you think that was
well thanks for having me trey
i think the democrats in the past have
been a little bit different than the
party that we see today
today's party
seems to believe that
they're in charge
and and previously i think both parties
recognize that
they work for the people the people
didn't work for them
so now you have uh
a party that is forcing things on people
that they don't want
and virginia was a very good example of
that uh it was a you know a purple state
or even almost a blue state
and yet the voting was much more
conservative in nature because people
want to maintain control of something
that is the most important thing when it
comes to their children and that's their
education you know i was a terrible
student
at one point in my life i thought i was
stupid
my parents my teachers and classmates
agreed and then my mother made me start
reading books
and i got to the point where i couldn't
stand to be without a book i became a
bookworm i i knew everything
and it completely changed the trajectory
of my life
and you know as someone who started out
in the lowest rungs of society
economically to be able to ascend to the
top one percent
you know that was not an accident that
was because of a solid education that
wasn't somebody teaching me about what
my gender was or what pronouns to use it
was about providing the appropriate type
of education that allows you to function
in our society
you know dr carlson i i wonder if the
pandemic
might have played a role because you
know the children were home more and the
parents had to be involved in education
and then i i mean i remember this is
anecdotal but this this video of it of
of a group of teachers
which was cringe-worthy
you know they couldn't go teach the kids
but they had time to go make this video
do you think the pandemic is kind of
what got maybe independent voters saying
well maybe the republicans are better on
this issue than i thought they were
there's no no
question that the pandemic played an
important role
in exposing what was going on you know a
lot of people think that this is new
this is not new that's been going on for
decades
implanting
what the left has considered to be
appropriate
people in order to fundamentally change
the way that our children are educated
and it's not really so much about
education as it is indoctrination and
it's exactly what nikita khrushchev had
in mind when he told eisenhower your
grandchildren's children will live under
communism and we won't have to fire a
shot if you can indoctrinate the kids
and you can control the media
then you have a tremendous advantage and
i think people are just now recognizing
that they're waking up i travel around
the country a lot
and i am very pleased to see so many
people getting involved with the school
board elections with the city council
elections making their presence known
not sitting around like wallflowers
a tremendous explosion in the
proliferation of
private schools and home schooling
and i i don't think that this is a
passing trend i think this is something
that's going to be with us for a while
and it's very encouraging quite frankly
you know dr carson it is so important i
mean tim scott talk about and i talk
about this all the time i mean education
is the closest thing to magic i mean i'm
not sure i believe you ever had bad
grades i know i did but even if you did
have bad grades to wind up
being a neurosurgeon and a cabinet level
secretary and a prolific offer and and a
presidential candidate i mean that
really does speak to the power of
education so
uh thank you for living what what what i
have said it is the closest thing to
magic that we have and you prove that
thank you so thank you for being a
patriot we appreciate you very much
yes sir you too dr carson hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else